sabrer dit ça fait un petit moment qu'on
s'est pas fait un seul vrai dit sous des
mots n'avaient découvert ça avec les
serrures d'ingénieurs encore aujourd'hui
je reçoive c'est pas tous les jours mais
à peu près toutes les semaines des
images de vous qui tombait à côté d'un
truc qui est un peu mal conçu et vous
dites et je vais l'envoyer à squeeze par
rapport à cette vidéo qu'il a derrière
un an et c'est trop mignon et un seul
résident qui attire mon attention parce
qu'il s'agit de l' inverse vraiment le
strict opposé d'un somme qu'on a fait à
quelques mois qui s'appelait le jass yes
no où c'était plein de vidéos qui
commençait très bien mais y avait un
élément qui foire est complètement et du
coup c'était stressant placez-le inverse
ça commence très mal et ça finit très
bien et du coup c'est très satisfaisant
a les traits de plaisanterie c'est parti
pour une vidéo qui s'appellera ça
commence mal mais ça finit bien
si c'est vraiment le titre ce magnifique
hockey premier zhang a player make the
ultimate move
ça va
je crois pas
s'ils croient pas mais
moi même grand père à la fin est étonné
ce qui vient de se passer c'est
réellement impressionnant au premier
degré tout cela parmi nous ossature fois
et quand on l'a fait et pas une légende
urbaine les amis il est possible de ne
pas perdre john gars même quand vous
retirez un étage je pensais vraiment que
c'était une légende urbaine non non il
va ya voir une baston un j'aime pas ça
ces moments là ça commence à chauffer à
faire le mâle alpha viril et que ça se
taper tout ça me met mal à l'aise bon
rires non non non non non non
[Musique]
oh
oh oh je vais essayer c'est hyper drôle
mais je veux totalement essayer ça a pas
l'air si tu en mets qui savent pas l'air
si dur quand tu as leurs corps et leurs
muscles
never give up
alerte tout le monde est bien celui d'un
cours barre d'une chaise musicale on
parle de la dernière chance d'une chaise
musicale aucun objet n'est plus sacré
que ça au monde aucun moment de ta vie
ne peut être plus stressant et sacré que
celui ci
a gagné elle va gagner
[Musique]
si ton mec ou ta copine se bat pour toi
comme cet homme s'est battu pour cette
chaise marie toi fini ta vie avec ou là
le manager qui empêche la décapitation
d'un chien à à cause de l'ascenseur
complexité
oh
la vache
je suis ému il faut créer un tipi faut
créer un tipi pour cet homme pour le
meilleur manager de l'histoire des
managers voie pour de vrai le timing
était tellement serré le chien arrivé à
la limite l'a appris il se faisait
écraser quoi alors ça c'est un truc
c'est ma hantise si vous avez un chien
ou que quelqu'un un chien que vous
prenez l'ascenseur fait super gaffe à ça
à ce que le chien soit bien l'endroit où
elles allaient ce parce que mec ton
chien bail il se pend quoi je seul c'est
déjà arrivé malheureusement je pense à
certains trous qui regarde cette vidéo
c'est pas une légende pour le coup ça
c'est pas comme le jingle ça arrive pour
de vrai et le gala un méga bon réflexe
il a été super fort c'est vraiment beau
je voudrais je suis vraiment ému c'était
serré qu est-ce qui était seul
je connaissais pas cette technique de
l'assiette neora tous l'appellent ce gag
de mettre la tête dans le gâteau mec si
vieux qu'est ce que c'est que ça oh non
non aux
barriques c'est exactement pour ça que
j'ai acheté un chargement beaux voiliers
qui sert à quoi ils rattrapent juste
montait lui laisser son utilité encore
un chat moi c'est un très grand saut il
entend taylor est ce que ça passera je
ne pense pas
je pense clairement qu'on sous-estimé
les chats je pense aux quais à la
prochaine à 50 minutes votre séduit
c'est du très sérieux
non c'est pas des chasseurs ou je sais
pas quoi ça va encore
ah ok c'est des mecs qui sait trop bien
c'est des gens qui vont sur la plage et
qui décroissent les animaux qui sont
coincés dans des dents des déchets donc
souvent du plastique je suppose a
souvent dit ça il va lui couper la tête
dans les secondes qui suivent la ccao
qui le plaque et le retire le truc en
plastique qu'elle a autour du goût
assez trop un magnifique ne jetez pas
vos déchets dans la mer football p1
saved by other players
[Musique]
hu
et sa version en acrosport la de ce côté
là ça a fini sur un terrain de foot mais
on sait où elle aurait dû finir dans des
gymnases bon hall à l'achat d'or qu'est
ce que j'aimerais le faire en vrai ça on
va tout sourit le faire mais on croit
tous être meilleur que ce qu'on voit
alors qu'on est beaucoup moins bon c'est
parti à lévis que tout
il n'ya pas de yes yao kayes assez
peut-être c'est peut-être un autre
candidat c'est peut-être un peu
candidate
deuxième aussi celui-là s'est terminée
aussi hostile a terminé en beauté c'est
lequel qui va réussir
c'est lui qui est notre héros
[Musique]
waouh sur destro mal à aller au milieu
passés au dessus de chacun et attendre
le bon alignement pour ça pue le sprint
je fais un petit débrief si jamais
certains se retrouve face à la même
épreuve par exemple au bac dans peu de
temps vous n'êtes pas à l'abri annoncé
le lancem h ça je connais j'en ai fais
ce que j'aime et et dans le mille
[Musique]
on connaît bien ça non clément bah oui
what
time et se sauver dit-il est ni cool
parce que ça finit toujours meilleur
mais me trèbes badens parce qu'il ya
plein de trucs que tu croyais des
légendes étudie mais non ça arrive
jamais c'est notre esprit du mal on
s'imagine des choses mais en fait des
fois ça arrive vraiment genre la hache
qui rebondit c'est exactement la peur
que j'avais quand je fais du cdh c'est
exactement celle là sachant que je
précise s'est pas défaussé h c'est
vraiment des vrais âge qui coupent
venerque l angoisse un skieur tombe
accidentellement d'une falaise mais là
la chance ce genre il a fait un saut il
n'a pas vu derrière que c'était si
assez exact
j'ai jamais été si content de voir un
mec faire là pokerface elvis au web et
vous voyez on regarde et c'est exact ans
vit depuis tout à l'heure c'est pareil
ça c'est à une peur que j'ai quand je
suis aussi j'ai quand tu vois basile
ader je me dis tout le temps ça se
trouve un méga trou c'est le bout de la
montagne je sais pas mais lui ça l'était
vraiment
what what what what what
wat mais pourquoi la france est chassée
par un
ah ils sont pas un [ __ ] white et
jacques mon petit coeur donc à l'abri ya
de l'émotion on est bien mais bon
pendant quelques secondes je vais vous
dire on n'est pas très bien corps est ok
on voit déjà les corses ont sculpté le
talent et
oies
c'est vraiment la face cachée de tous
les spectacles impressionnants à voir où
les humains font des trucs incroyables
il ya eu des centaines de fois oui oui
s'est passé ça qu'est ce que c'est que
ça
pardon
pardon mec tu deviens parano asturiens
que les eaux comme ça c'est fou il sort
de sa coquille comme un petit poucet
mais cette destination finale on dirait
pas vraiment destination finale là c'est
abusé mec
[Musique]
non non non je refuse de regarder s'il
vous plaît est en train de raviver un
traumatisme aulas à vao j'en ai assez
souffert bon c'est quoi aller j'accepte
dorian
wet
alors la veille à la mecque on est sur
un style qui n'a aucun sens là je remets
quand même
d'accord donc le mec a calculé le fait
que l'une des branches à l'escale eder
le câble et que ça allait ensuite mettre
un couple dans le bon sens à la peluche
on peut s'appeler de mon skill à moi
s'il vous plaît sur les ufo catcher
vendent rapidement annexe n'est pas plus
on n'a vraiment pas le même talent
vraiment pas à temps non non ne me dis
pas que c'est arrivé deux fois est pas
une c'est impossible les scientifiques
l'ont démontré ça ne peut arriver qu'une
seule fois par siècle mais la vidéo date
portant du même siècle que l'autre nord
[Musique]
j'ai envie de faire un jogging avec vous
au attendait choix qui sert au hockey on
assiste là un tentacule qui essaie
d'attaquer un crabe et qui va gagner
tenta cruel va peut-être tenté la charge
attention
tentacules avec titan de la soukra bic
et steve immédiatement rabiti continuer
à esquiver ce qui m'est arrivé à ben
dhia rotariens qui se joint au combat et
qui sauve in extremis le petit kraby qui
d'ailleurs attendait est en train
d'évoluer
et bien les amis c'est la fin de ce non
non non je pense superflus en fait dans
mes vidéos le casque isolde ouf le bruit
aux alentours et du coup je parle de mes
gars forts car je m'entends pas une
information peu pertinente
j'espère que ça aurait dit vous a plu je
trouve ça cool parce qu'il a vraiment du
bon mood c'est vraiment beaucoup de
positif beaucoup de trucs cool on a vu
que certaines légendes urbaines étaient
en réalité ouais on va essayer de pas
être parano prochain dans ses tâches
qu'on fait c'est comme si on faisait du
lan 7 h toutes les semaines n'oubliez
pas alors de vos prochaines parties de
jenga tout est possible ne baissez
jamais les bras au maire j'aurais fait
ça c'est incroyable allez atterrir
c'était le seul vrai dit number three de
la chaîne je crois que c'est le
troisième à tenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]